il
[Musique]
alors michel vous allez devoir effectuer
cinq donc se rassurer vos michel pas de
costumes pas de perruque rien voilà
juste des gens qui vont venir danser
avec vous pendant 15 secondes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
merci
[Applaudissements]
ok
tu sais
mais pas
[Musique]
et
ça c'est mon michel
c'est michel à vue ils sont très bien
foutu et chroniqueur oui oui c'est mieux
ça pose pour rattraper le corps du
patron
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peut-être veut-il lévis mais valérie
mais les chiens jeanne ou flamenco
quelle incroyable franchement vous êtes
une fraîcheur
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais
[Musique]
à
mais qui fait tout
sous le p
[Musique]
les fugitifs
ouah
ça lui va bien merci là ça suffit ça va
et plus que tranquille je n'ai qu'une
heure d'entraînement
enfin en cinquante ans le site là michel
drucker qui est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]